Washington journal continues want to
welcome back to our table near Neil
Irwin economics reporter with The
Washington Post here to talk about
testimony yesterday by both the Treasury
secretary in the federal reserve
chairman ben bernanke about the European
debt crisis kneel before we get talking
let me show one moment from yesterday
where the Treasury Secretary was asked
about the current economic situation in
our country our economy is gradually
getting stronger but of course we still
face a lot of tough challenges here in
the United States among those challenges
of course unemployment still very high
housing market still very weak we still
have a long way to go to repair the
damage caused by a crisis but we also
face a challenging and uncertain global
economic environment with the risks
around Iran adding to upward pressure on
oil prices and Europe facing a long and
difficult crisis Europe euro area
accounts for about eighteen percent of
global gdp it's a major source of
financing from edgy many emerging
economies it accounts for about fifteen
percent of US exports of goods and
services but a larger portion of the
exports of many of our trading partners
when growth slows in Europe it affects
growth around the world Neil Irwin help
us read between the lines there sure
what what the Treasury secretary is
saying is things are a little better the
Europe crisis has eased a lot since last
fall the US economy shows some signs of
picking up but nothing that they can
really thump their chests about and say
look happy times are here again it's
still very challenging economic
environment higher gas prices or
pinching Americans wallets and you know
that's that that's those fundamentals
are there so he's trying to kind of
thread a needle and the two sides are on
the one hand things are getting better
on the other hand we understand they're
not as much better as we would all like
on the European debt crisis what's to
watch for next that could change the
progress that has been made yeah I think
the the things to think about in Europe
are is there now the political will to
do the things that the countries have
promised they're going to do so what
we've seen over the last year is a bunch
of promises to create these giant
backstops to prevent any
defaults in Europe you know greece in
some of the other countries that are in
financial difficulty are going to cut
their spending are going to do these
structural changes to their economy to
try and become more competitive now the
question is can they carry out those
things they promised to is there you
know is there the political will to do
some very painful cuts you can imagine
in this country if suddenly you know
government pensions and social security
are going to be cut by twenty thirty
percent you would have a lot of
unhappiness and the real out of
resistance to that well the same is true
in Greece and they're being asked to
make changes on that kind of scale that
are just very dramatic and shaping their
public public system if they don't make
those changes what's the impact on
global institutions like the IMF well
the you know the truth is the global
institutions the IMF the the other
European country is the European Central
Bank which is also played a very
important role in this they do have
leverage and they've been essentially
funding the Greek government and to
varying degrees some of the others
Portugal and Ireland the question is do
they do they back off and let the rate
rise and let pressure build and try and
force force the hand of Greek
politicians to to do things they've
already agreed to do and it's it's a
very tough situation and it's a very
fragile situation because this is a
country that is you know under its its
economies in terrible shape there's been
a lot of economic contraction and that
really strange society it strange a
political system so will that will that
Center hold in in Greece in some of the
other countries that are doing very
painful changes as well what does all of
this mean then for the US taxpayer for
the US taxpayer there's not much risk in
terms of financial loss not like you
know we're shipping dollars over to
Europe that we're not going to get back
or to the IMF we are the major
shareholder the IMF we're the largest
shareholder the IMF so in theory if the
IMF incurred losses those would be our
losses but for example the Federal
Reserve is extending loans to the ECB
it's called a swap line there's not
really financial risk there for the US
taxpayer it's they they send dollars
over they get euros back and then they
unwind it three months later so that's
that's not a terribly risky thing that
said the risk for the for America is
that is that things really go wrong and
the risk is that you know this thing
that's moved in a pretty orderly
direction the last four or five months
goes the other way
and suddenly US companies to do business
over there in trouble suddenly us
exporter's are in trouble suddenly the
global financial markets start to
implode again and just a secretary
Geithner told Congress yesterday that he
the Obama administration would not
return to the members and ask for more
money for the IMF what do you make of
that yeah I mean part of that's the
reality that to go in an election year
to a Republican House of Representatives
and say hey guys we need we need more
money for this international
organization that is because but we need
to support Europeans I think that would
not go over terribly well but there's
also just the reality that as things are
going so far there's not a need for more
resources the existing institutions seem
to be able to handle these the existing
situation let's get two phone calls here
first one is patty a Republican in
Minneapolis you're up first here for
Neil Irwin of the Washington Post good
morning I wondered all earlier this week
it was either monday or tuesday your
paper wrote a lengthy article regarding
john boehner trying to negotiate with
obama and that he gave him what he
wanted and this is regarding the budget
and Obama refused and it talked about
his Obama's arrogance and incompetents
in negotiating and that Boehner had
agreed to raise taxes basically making
Obama an offer he shouldn't have refused
oh and if you could expound on that and
also CBO recently came out with a report
about the actual new cost of Obamacare
that is I think about 1.7 trillion
that's getting no press on c-span could
you talk about those do you know what
I'm talking about that article yeah I
didn't write so I didn't write that
article I I did read it and my
colleagues wrote it my read was was a
little different than yours it that the
piece so the piece ran in Sunday's
Washington Post and explained some of
the inside story of these net debt
ceiling negotiations that happened last
summer that led to ultimately being
extended but there were some moments
where it looked like there was close to
being a grand bargain a big deal on on a
strategy to reduce the budget deficit
over time
you know from from my read of that
article and my colleagues reporting it's
it's a little more complicated than the
way the caller describes it definitely
was the case that you know Obama started
to have cold feet about a deal that was
on the table but it's also pretty clear
that that Boehner and Eric Cantor we're
not sure if they could pass past that
plan that included some tax increases in
the House of Representatives you know
it's certainly true anytime there's
negotiation that breaks down i think
that the two sides have very different
views of whose fault it was and and what
went wrong this one I don't think you
can you can put it entirely on on one
side and it was at the end of the day it
was Boehner who walked away as my
understanding I should be careful this
because I'm you know I don't cover the
legislative side of things very often
but that's that's my read I'm not sure
about the CBO health care report I'm not
up to speed on that this is a tweet here
from a viewer wants to know it appears
both the US and Europe cannot compete in
the new world free markets they created
tariffs ? can the US and Europe compete
I think that overstates it you know the
truth is we are still the United States
is still the world's biggest economy and
Europe collectively is is the second
biggest and you know that that may
change eventually China may eventually
surpass us certainly because they have a
much bigger population but on a per
capita basis it'll it's not foreseeable
the China surpasses the United States or
Europe in terms of economic output you
know we went for kind of high-grade
services for high-grade manufactured
good airplanes the stuff that's really
hard to make it's still the case that
the US and Europe are better at it and
our workers are more efficient at it
than in most developing nations and you
see that in our overall wage structure
you know whether tariffs are a good idea
or not i think is kind of disconnected
to how we're competing and i think most
economist would say that's actually
going to impede the ability of us to
find the things we're best at and do
them better than anybody else Eric a
democratic caller in Atlanta Georgia
good morning hi I got a comment and a
question uh thanks for taking my call by
the way I got a comment a question um my
comment is um
you know about c-span itself it seems
like ninety-nine percent of your
questions is about the future like
what's going to happen in the future so
I would just encourage you span to
analyze what has happened in the past
give them to the public little
background give the public a little
context of about the issue instead of
speculating about the future was nobody
knows my question is could could the
guest expand on how Bush allowed China
into the WTO cave China most favored
nation status and China was flush with
cash so they decided to invest in Wall
Street the investment in wall street
cause Wall Street to pay mortgage
lenders a bonus is to get these subprime
loans out so whilst we would have a way
to sell stuff to investors so China's
WTO status both favorite nation status
from the Bush administration caused all
of this mess and this is not a European
debt crisis this is a greased debt
crisis can you give some background on
the financial transactions yeah so I
wouldn't agree with the entire kind of
framework that the caller laid out there
is aspect of truth to it though which is
that what happened in the 2000s was when
one term port is is the global savings
glut so China other asian nations were
dramatically increasing their savings
they had all this so they were running
trade surpluses so they had more money
coming in than then then going out and
they had to save that money somewhere
they need to invest it somewhere and
that's somewhere in China and a lot of
other places disproportionately became
US Securities so that included US
Treasury bonds debt from Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac that was backed by mortgages
in some cases private-label
mortgage-backed securities in fact you
know so this this this a lot of savings
so there's all the savings from around
the world including Asia including
Europe as well that was finding its way
into triple-a rated dollar-denominated
securities so that is kind of the
ultimate source of the money that
ultimately funded subprime mortgages you
know is that purely a China story you
know it's it's bigger than China but
China is certainly part of it it's also
part of you know German savings it's
also part of wealthy individuals in the
oil producing countries it's it's
broader than than just China but what
happened is you had all this money
chasing these these small pool
securities and so some of that money
found its way into subprime lending that
was ultimately making mortgages that
were not very good mortgages and that's
really how we got into this mess on our
Republican line Frank in Beltsville
Maryland oh yes I'm on now this question
goes back to a little bit to Spector but
to the guest the question has to do or
with some back to public health and its
effect on economy and how that ripples
through the globe and I'll particularly
go to the drug situation worldwide but
just to stay in north america and the
cartels and the billions that are lost
at the economy that is affected there
and affects the the recession because of
the billions involved or how do you look
at that as an impact on the debt crisis
even into europe for the just the
situation that the weakness of the
people that use recreational drugs and
it fuels these things which lead to the
war and economic disarray and i would
just go back even to lincoln for one
thing if the guest or you could mention
something literally from forwards or
five words with malice toward none and
charity toward all how do we go to those
things as they affect the economy in the
end the peace lr 1 i'm not sure how much
illegal drugs have to do with with
europe crisis but its problem on both
sides of the Atlantic Janesville
Wisconsin Hector Democratic caller go
ahead yes good morning why are we still
subsidizing the big corporations like
General Electric oil companies and so
and so
in our congressman paul ryan here so how
could i put it cutting benefits for
seniors and victories and all that you
know and yet he goes around giving tax
breaks to the one percent okay so Hector
do you have a question that's it this my
question well you know the so the
question becomes what is the what is the
tax strategy the tax policies that would
make our economy strongest and most
innovative and competitive and you know
one philosophy says you you keep very
low tax rates on things like capital
gains that encourage investment and and
that will in turn incentivize you know
job creation starting businesses
entrepreneurship and that'll have
benefits for everybody the alternative
theory as well you know what if you do
that you're what you're really doing is
giving very low taxes to the people who
already have the most money and
shouldn't you in fact lower taxes or
have higher taxes on the high income and
lower taxes on the low and mid income
people and they'll be better off I mean
that's the central ideological and an
economic policy debate between the two
parties that has been playing out for
many years and will certainly be playing
out in this 2012 election Treasury
secretary Geithner and the Federal
Reserve Chairman Ben Bernanke up on
Capitol Hill yesterday talking about the
European debt crisis in the US economy
that's our topic here this morning Neil
Irwin and the US economy how much does
it depend on the European economy so on
one on one side the direct linkages are
fairly modest our US exports to Europe
or two three percent of GDP it's it's
not massive what we've seen over the
last two years though is that the
connections are really more profound
than then then it might have appeared
and what we've seen is whenever your
flares up whenever their crisis seems to
be getting worse their markets are
gyrating and things seem to be going out
of control it seems to show up in the US
data pretty quickly in terms of job
creation and everything else we saw that
in the spring of 2010 we saw it in the
the summer of two thousand eleven and
that's dangerous that means
that these languages they happen through
the financial system so you know if the
European markets are on the verge of
collapse or gyrating wildly the US
market does the same and so that hurts
business confidence maybe employers
don't want to hire if they're worried
that Europe might collapse any day now
and so that clearly has been something
that's held back employers and I think
part of the reason we've seen some
better economic data and better job
creation in the last few months is that
some of that risk some of that fear has
been put aside and employers are saying
well you know maybe the Europeans have
figured their stuff out and now I feel a
little more comfortable adding adding
adding jobs when it comes to the global
market and gas and oil prices President
Obama going on the offense on a four-day
tour right now to talk about what he was
trying to do for gasoline prices but how
much is the u.s. prices dictated by
factors outside of the United States
overwhelmingly so you know the u.s. we
are a major oil producer we are a major
oil consumer but it is a global market
and you know there's a lot more oil
coming from Middle East and and and
elsewhere then from the United States
and and US sellers are free to ship
their oil over but to China or wherever
else if that's what the economics favor
so the reality is that the price of oil
is set on a global market in the longer
run you know what US does the United
States has some supply side matters in
the short run it doesn't in the short
run the major determines our how much is
how much economic growth is there in
China and India if there's more that's
more demand for oil that pushes prices
up what happens in Iran if there's more
political turbulence in the Middle East
that could reduce supplies cut supply
chains those are the things that will
determine what the gas prices are over
the next year over the longer term
that's where energy efficiency matters
that's where exploration matters and
drilling more and becoming more
efficient could really make a difference
over the longer time horizon The
Washington Post your paper has this
headline this morning Saudi Arabia seeks
to calm global oil markets President
Obama may be traveling in the country
this week to tout his energy policy but
the oil markets attention is focused on
Saudi Arabia and its production plans
the kingdom's oil minister insisted this
week that oil markets are amply supplied
and then it stands ready to boost output
its Council of Ministers asserted that
excessively high petroleum prices
the global economy and that a downturn
would lead to an abrupt pullback in
prices hurting the interests of oil
exporters and consumers how much of an
impact is a headline like this make and
and and the move by Saudi Arabia yeah we
just can see what they do you know
there's an interesting dynamic here
where the oil producers the major oil
producers like Saudi Arabia their
incentive is not to make oil prices as
high as they could possibly be they have
a more complicated set of incentives
because if prices get too high then
suddenly people will start investing
more heavily and energy efficiency in
other forms of energy you know on the
electrical side wind and nuclear and
other things so they want to make sure
there's going to be demand for their oil
over many many years and so to do that
they have to not let prices get too high
or but be too volatile so you know the
Saudis have an interest in not letting
oil prices get too out of control
question is how much capacity do they
actually have and is there spare
capacity in the system to try and
produce more and therefore lean against
some of the some of the disruptions that
are that are threatening prices Gary on
twitter says will the europeans really
be able to wean themselves off of
government feeding too will there be
more riots in the streets what is the
end result you know it's we've already
seen quite a few riots there's been
peaceful protests in a lot of countries
and in Greece it's been not always
peaceful you know the thing is it's
tough you know any time you're making
huge structural adjustments in how an
economy works there's going to be paying
there's a reason if these were easy
decisions it would have been made years
ago the fact that some of these changes
in the European social welfare state are
being made under duress from the IMF and
the European Commission and as part of a
bailout package rather than just being
done by a parliament kind of on its own
accord is a sign of how you know how
deeply entrenched in these things are
it's true even you know Greece is a kind
of extreme example just because they're
doing such dramatic cuts even in say
Spain where they have a labor market
that has a lot of regulations that
really make it hard to to employ people
hard to hire they have twenty percent
unemployment in spain so what they're
trying to do is liberalize that labor
market so that employers feel more
comfortable and more flexible about
being able to hire somebody because they
know they can file
if it doesn't work out but you know that
labor market has evolved over many years
and is and has a lot of entrenched
interests behind it so it's there's a
lot of strain and trying to make those
changes the question is is is the
outside pressure on these countries to
make these changes from from Germany
from the other European countries that
are essentially supporting them
financially is that strong enough to
kind of force these things through the
national parliaments so far it is will
that political a minimum hold is a
different question on our line for
independence James in Richmond Virginia
my ideal I Neil my question is could you
add a little more color if your earlier
statement that Here Come is just a
little better I'm thinking back to the
fall of two thousand eight one we're
losing over 70,000 jobs the month and
where the come is contracting little
where we are today we're more super not
concern about lineage of them all about
getting better judgment what I get in
bed just as well like things are
significantly a lot better than anywhere
right maybe it's know where you want to
be but I think in anything you're
reporting I think it's important to be
honest about where we where three years
ago where we are now I kinda figured
that's a point James so so there's the
direction in the level so it's certainly
true that the direction of things is far
better than it was in late two thousand
eight early 2009 there we were you know
shrinking by five seven nine percent a
quarter at an annual rate so that was a
period of very steep decline we were
shutting hundreds of thousands of jobs a
month those were very dark days now what
happened the economy bottomed out in the
summer of two thousand nine and it's
then since then it's been very very
gradually creeping back up so what we're
growing at now though is it looks like
the first quarter growth is going to be
around two percent as the quarter that
ends in a week or two two percent isn't
great two percent isn't climbing out of
the hole we're in two percent is just
kind of going back to the baseline kind
of normal rate of growth that would be
fine if we were at full employment if we
had five six percent unemployment and we
had we were growing at two percent that
would be fine but we're not we're at
eight eight point three percent
unemployment and so the rate were
growing that the pace were growing at is
not fast enough to really put people
back to work and
of numbers it's not fast enough to put
us back on the kind of trajectory were
on before 2007 before this recession
started so I absolutely agree that that
we're in a much better spot than we were
two years ago because we're not in the
middle of this deep die this deep
decline but neither have we really claw
our way out of it or really are we doing
so at a pace that's going to get us back
to normal anytime soon angola indiana
done democratic holler yeah the CVO
yesterday graded ryan's budget plan and
just like the austerity measures and
europe he seems to want to take all the
the pain of getting us out of this on
the backs of those who can least afford
it see the elderly the you know the poor
how does he do you think that that such
as didn't work in he replied it why does
he think that you know less consumer
ability to to buy things is going to
work here when it didn't work there and
why are they so adamant about not
touching the the higher-end taxes when
it hasn't created any jobs in the last
ten years why is it going to magically
start now that's all thanks well I think
you just saw a preview of an argument
that the president in the Democrats we
making this this election year you know
it's it's again I think Paul Ryan's
argument would be that by by cutting
taxes on on on the wealthy on investment
on on business and by you know cutting
spending on on social programs and
having a leaner government that would
free up a much more conducive
environment for entrepreneurship much
more conducive environment for growth
you know you're right that there's you
know reason to think that first of all
cutting spending too fast would be a
drain on the economy the question is
whether the confidence instilling
effects on business are strong enough to
make up for that short-term drain you
know this is the this is the fundamental
idea logical argument of our times and I
think yet paul ryan's budget is just one
step in a very long debate that's going
to happen over the course of the year
which countries should us viewers be
watching that are making strides in the
global amarte and market that might
surprise them and people talk a lot
about China and
but what are some other countries to
watch so in among the developing
countries you know there's a number this
has been a remarkable last decade for
for growth in a lot of emerging
countries and what's happened is is it's
amazing how many places you know
literally billions of people on earth
are becoming or entering the global
middle class as some of these countries
grow Brazil is a great example Indonesia
is a huge country that has been very
poor in the past and is kind of joining
the global middle class as is China and
you mention India is is also enormous
you know this is one of the great in a
way it's one of the great under-covered
stories of our time there's there's you
know it's it's a wonderful story
actually it you know does come at a cost
it comes the cost of higher fuel prices
and higher demand for for things that
kind of middle-class people want but it
also means that a lot fewer people are
living in dire poverty than was the case
ten years ago during in Colorado
ordering County excuse me during County
New Jersey Chris Republican there you go
Neil good morning I hey my customer for
you is do you see Portugal requiring
another bailout and if so what do you
believe the implications for financial
markets will be a Portugal's interesting
case it's a small country their finances
are kind of a mess you know whether
whether they actually have to go back to
the IMF and the and the European
Commission and have another package I
you know I just don't know you know
their their problem is one of their kind
of the the poor man in Europe they're
one of the poorer countries they're
small the good thing about Portugal is
because they're small their problems are
manageable if if they need more help the
IMF can afford that the the European
governments can afford that the the real
firewall thing you have to worry about
is Spain in Italy which are just far
larger economies if they run into
trouble then then it becomes a very
difficult problem for the world
community to deal with because there are
much bigger countries Portugal you know
they've been doing a bunch of reforms
they're tough there's a they're not very
popular domestically in Portugal but
their government so far has been pretty
consistent and moving forward and living
up to the terms of its of its aid
packages
people have talked a lot about Greece
but some of the other countries Ireland
Spain what is what what are the health
of those economies yet varies in the
exact nature of the problem of the
crisis in these different countries has
been different greece greece was
spending way beyond its means Greece had
huge budget deficits they were lying and
misleading about the scale of those
budget deficits and the accumulated debt
Greece is kind of its own problem it is
it is by far the worst financial problem
in Europe Ireland had actually quite
good finances going into the the crisis
it has a pretty efficient economy it has
a you know labour markets that work well
however it had a banking crisis it had
way too much lending on on real estate
banks that were at risk of going under
government props up the banks and
suddenly the government of a fairly
small country is on the hook for these
liabilities of a banking system that had
gotten way too big and was really
exposed they're plotting along and you
know those underlying competitive drinks
in their economy probably bode well for
the future they you know have the
potential to as they move past this huge
debt that they incurred from backing up
their banking system they have the
potential move forward we took just
talked about Portugal Spain is you know
a large economy their problems are also
in the labor market they have strange
person employment I mentioned earlier
but they're you know they're making
changes they're trying to figure out how
to make sure that young people can get
jobs right now if you're a young person
in Spain it's very hard to get a job
because jobs are held on to by older
people under a very rigid kind of work
rules system Italy is as even bigger
than Spain Italy's you know making
progress they have a new government that
replaced Silvio Berlusconi last summer
they're plotting along making these
changes you know it's it's a it's funny
we have all these countries trying to do
these stay these debates that we have in
the United States over you know what
should the social safety net look like
and what should tax levels be and what
should our deficits be how quickly
should we try and reduce those deficits
without you know ruining our economy and
keeping growth on track those are the
same the entire industrialized world is
grappling with those exact same
questions and the politics are different
each country and the priorities are
different each country but those basic
questions or everybody's dealing with in
the same time back to the US economy
this is from the AP wire this morning
the number of people seeking on
ployment aid in the u.s. fell to a
four-year low last week bolstering the
view that the job market has
strengthened Labor Department says
weekly applications dropped five
thousand to a seasonally adjusted
348,000 your reaction Neil Irwin on this
news that's good you know this has been
a real area of progress for a few months
now is uh you know every week the labor
department puts out these numbers on how
many people last week filed new claims
for unemployment insurance benefits and
what it is it's kind of a real time
indicator of how many people are losing
their jobs are being are being laid off
or thrown out of work and the fact that
in fact that sounds like the lowest
number we've had in years I don't
remember a lord four-year lot before
your Lea so lowest lowest since 2008
that's a good sign now there's a weird
thing happening the labor market right
now that the the number of people losing
their jobs being fired is down quite a
lot what hasn't picked up quite enough
yet is hires so one side of the ledger
is fires and the other side is hires
fires are down that's good but hires
aren't up enough to really move the
numbers as much and which side tells us
what's going on with a long-term
unemployed you know what we really want
to see is hires what we really want to
see look it's great that fewer people
are losing their jobs but what it kind
of is is a labor market frozen in place
what's happening is employers are no
longer slashing jobs and and that's a
good sign but at the same time they're
only now starting to say well you know
that there's enough demand for my
products I'm confident enough in the
future I'm going to bring people back on
i'm gonna i'm going to add another shift
i'm going to bring you know add hours
i'm going to bring another five people
onto my shift that's that's starting to
happen it's having more the last few
months but still not happening in the
kind of massive numbers that would that
would really put the long-term
unemployed back to work another tweet
for you hear from Jim Heintz at what
percentage must GDP grow in order to
achieve full employment and then he has
a second question once to take that
first one yep so um so here's how the
map works the US economy is constantly
adding popular labor forces constantly
growing there's immigration there's the
young people graduating from high school
and college joining the workforce so
there's always growing labor force and
people are always becoming more more
productive so productivity is is almost
always rising that means that we are
capable as a country of making more
stuff year after year
most people think that number is
something like two two and a half
percent is how much our capacity to make
stuff grows every year what that means
is we need to grow at least that rate
two to two and a half percent just to
kind of keep up just to stay neutral
just to just just keep people employed
and not have a rising unemployment so
right now we're at eight percent
unemployment to bring that down we would
really need to grow faster than that
three four percent would be great if we
could have that for a few years then
that unemployment rate would come down
then once we're down to five or six
percent then you can go back to going to
two and a half percent in GDP and and
and it'll be fine Lawton Oklahoma bill
Democratic caller hello morning bell
good morning yes I had a question about
the United Nations agenda 21 and if
anybody doesn't know about United
Nations agenda 21 they really need to
look it up online but how do you see the
United Nations agenda 21 how do you see
it affecting all of America's economy
right now because the Republican
National Committee has passed a
unanimous resolution stating that they
recognized as a real and there they are
against it how do you see a nationwide
how do you see us stopping the UN agenda
21 effort here in America yell or when
are you up to date on that enough we'll
go on burlington wisconsin david
independent caller that's good morning
thanks for taking my call such a
beautiful smile you have I'm you know
Paul Ryan I'm in his district and you're
just at a call from Janesville about
paul ryan's budget and how to fix the US
economy at his listening sessions here
in the first District of Wisconsin Paul
Ryan will use those listening sessions
to ram home the fear that our economy
might take a nosedive alike the European
economy has done but I asked Paul Ryan
well isn't Germany doing quite well and
he just ignored my question and
blew it off and went directly to Greece
is that that is where our primary focus
should be because he wants to instill
fear but Germany's doing quite well in
Germany is doing quite well because
their government is patterned after our
government after we succeeded in World
War two and destroying fascism at least
on this side of the Western Wall well
let's have nail respondent is Germany
doing well and and what about them
patterning their system after ours yeah
the German economy is doing pretty well
a number of the you know the Netherlands
Austria number the Nordic countries are
doing pretty well Sweden Denmark you
know what's there's a tendency to try
and say okay you know having having a
large social welfare state like most
European countries do means you have
high deficits and all the stuff that
Greece has well the truth is that can
happen but it can also be the case that
you have a large social welfare state
coupled with fiscal responsibility and
and that's what they have in Germany
they have you know of socialized health
care they have a lot of things that that
Americans you know may not want but but
they are able to do that in the context
of fiscal stability and and not letting
deficits get out of control and so I
think it conflates the issue and look
the United States is not grease grease
is you know really in terms of how that
government is run the decisions they
were making the choices they were making
before before the crisis they're in a
different scale than anything we've done
with our deficits here Phil greg has
this tweet would raising taxes on job
creators businesses with high demand for
their products cause them to stop hiring
and stop producing what do you hear from
your business sources look tax policy
definitely affects investment decisions
I've talked to executives over the years
who you know have to decide am I going
to open this this new factory and in the
United States and Michigan or in Germany
and you know if our corporate tax rate
is higher than over there that's one
more reason or one reason not to not to
build it here and not create jobs here
you know corporate tax policy absolutely
matters and it is something that the
businesses are weighing as they decide
where to invest you know the thing is
it's it's
look look politics is about trade-offs
and governments about trade-offs and
economic policies about trade-offs and
figure out what our priorities are as a
society and you know what our tax policy
is going to be as a result is you know
that's what elections are for forward
texts Linda on the Republican line
you're up next yes mr. Irwin I I would
like to know if um I'm sorry I am trying
to fix this and i'm not sure like it you
can hear me yeah we can hear you go
ahead with your question all right i was
wondering why are is it always social
programs that are in not on in our
country and in other countries that's
where politicians always go to weed out
the fraud the poor people are ripping
off everybody and the politicians
balance their campaign in other
countries not in our country ah there's
no economic recovery where I live people
are not getting put back to work
everybody in the United States pays
taxes if they've got a cell phone at
least twenty dollars probably that cell
phone bill goes to pay taxes all right
now I run anything there to respond to
look why do politicians in the focusing
on on social programs when they're
looking to cut budget deficits because
that's where the money is now there's
some ideological aspects involved as
well and and different parties and
different people have different
priorities of what they want to cut but
you know my colleague Ezra Klein has a
line that if you look at the US
government and what it spends money on
its it's basically a retirement
insurance organization that happens to
have a military attached to it if you
look at where the big money is in the US
budget it's Social Security it's
Medicare its Medicaid and it's the end
it's the military adding that at an
interest on the on the
on the debt and that covers most of what
the US government spends money on
everything else is kind of crammed into
a smaller piece of the pie chart so if
you know if you're looking at you know
right now we have a deficit that's you
know and then in the neighborhood of its
over trillion dollars trillion and half
dollars if you have to try and reduce
that deficit over time and you're trying
to make a meaningful reduction you know
cutting cutting little things here and
there isn't going to do it you have to
kind of go at the things where the money
is really being spent and that happens
to be social welfare programs along with
the military and michael ray bush has
that speaks to that on on twitter with
his tweet do you think that a cut in our
military spending could help our economy
well this gets back to so in this short
run if if we cut too fast whether its
military or anything else it can reduce
economic growth if you cut too fast
that's sucking money out of the economy
that's so in the military case that's
less money being spent on tanks and
airplanes and so the people who build
those tanks and airplanes might lose
their jobs now in the longer run as we
try and figure out a way to chart a path
toward a more sustainable fiscal path i
think most people say that military is
going to have to be part of that because
again it's one of the big areas where
where the money is being spent so this
gets back to this tricky balance of
trying to to get the tested under
control but on the right timing in a
careful way that doesn't undermine our
recovery and stop us from from from
gaining jobs on our line for Democrats
in Bowie Maryland Connie's watching us
go ahead Connie good morning what I
wanted to say is history tells us that
the way we got out of depression before
was by building things like our
infrastructure if we would have passed a
bill to build our infrastructure we
could pay off our debt quicker than
cutting social problems we can't cut in
that in order to cut us out of debt but
if we put people back to work building
our roads and bridges and schools we can
pay our debt off much quicker all right
on that point me Lauren I think a lot of
economist would agree with you you know
that we have very low interest rates
right now so the US government can
borrow money for you know two percent
for ten years which is remarkably low
risen a little bit in the last couple
weeks but interest rates are low we have
a lot of infrastructure apart from
building new roads and new bridges and
things like that there's just the upkeep
there's the kind of required maintenance
that we've been deferring because
money's been tight raw materials so
labor is cheaper so you can give
unemployed construction workers who
definitely want a job so you can hire
them for cheaper than you would in a
stronger economy I think a lot of
economist would say you know this last
three years we should have been doing a
kind of national reinvestment in our in
our infrastructure and getting our roads
in good shape and borrowing money to do
it it's one thing to borrow money for
those things have a long-term payoff
that's a that's a smarter thing than
borrowing money just to fund this year's
consumptions the equivalent of a family
it's one thing to borrow money to buy a
house because the house last for a long
time it's another to borrow money just
to pay your grocery bill that's that's
more concerning it's it's so far been a
missed opportunity has been something
that there's has not been been that
bipartisan ability to come around to
investing in a large scale on
infrastructure and I think it's very
possible that in the years ahead we'll
look back at the 2008 to 2012 period is
kind of a missed opportunity to really
invest in that area Annapolis Joe and
independent their your last phone call
here for neil irwin go ahead hey i got a
question for you sir um i travel around
the states a lot and every time I've
been in every single newspaper I see has
help wanted ads in it and my point is if
there are so few jobs why are there so
many help wanted ads everywhere I go and
why isn't unemployment dropping faster
that's my question there's some
mismatches you know there's there's in
some cases the skills that that people
have or not matches for the jobs that
are available you know part of this is
kind of a structural readjustment of
getting people prepared and trained and
ready for the jobs of the 21st century
not the not the jobs they had in the
past part of its just look there's
always turn in the labor market so even
in the in the darkest days of the
recession there were still empty jobs
you know there's always kind of a
matching time period I mean I think it
is true though that we're starting to
see more of those help wanted ads and
signs and all the all the indicators
including today's a jobless claims
number point to a labor market that's
starting to get a little tighter now
it's still there's still a lot of you
know still millions people unemployed
and
still progress we made but there I think
we'll hear more and more of those
stories of employers ready to hire
looking to hire and and just a matter of
finding the right people Miller when
coming up here and for our last 40
minutes or so we're going to ask our
viewers take on President Obama's energy
strategy on gas prices what should
people be watching for look the energy
prices I know everybody worries well so
what's what's gonna be the price of gas
between now in the election how does
that affect the outcome of the election
it's a very frustrating thing for people
in the White House and and as they look
at this because in the short term they
have virtually no levers to adjust it
you know there's the Strategic Petroleum
Reserve that's really for emergencies
not for not for just a an election year
you know the Bush administration had
this in 2008 when there was a big run-up
in the summer of two thousand eight
which probably hurt her John McCain's
popularity you know the truth is the
price of oil is termed by supply and
demand on supply side is their war in
Iran is there more instability in the
Middle East that could damage supply
side and drive prices up does the global
economy does China India Europe do those
economies say on track and keep needing
more oil that would increase the demand
side that would also increase prices
unfortunately the thing that would drive
prices down would be for for that demand
to soften which is probably not we want
either and speculators the role of them
look it sits there there is financial
speculation and energy over time to view
that as the look over time if people are
speculating and the price gets beyond
fundamentals eventually those
speculators are going to lose money in
the short run yes in the short run
financial speculation can drive up the
price of oil in ways that don't make
sense given the fundamentals of supply
and demand but that will catch up with
them eventually and over the longer term
it's hard to see how how that's the
issue with that as our foundation for a
discussion coming up we'll turn our
attention to President Obama's energy
strategy Neil Irwin thank you very much
for being here thanks great news update
first and then we'll be back with your
take on President Obama's energy
strategy it's 922 a.m. eastern time with
the number of people seeking
unemployment aid falling to a four-year
lo last week word this hour that
Volkswagen will be creating eight
hundred new jobs at its chattanooga
plant the company planning to ramp up
production of their Passat this will
bring the total new positions at that
plant to 1000 this year more on the
shooting of a teenager in Florida last
week from Chris tuck co-director of the
National neighborhood watch programs in
remarks earlier he says it's highly
unusual for watch members to carry a
weapon and highly discouraged he says
the groups are intended to be the eyes
and ears of police not law enforcement
themselves mr. Tucker went on to say
that he was flabbergasted to learn that
a Florida watch captain shot and killed
an unarmed black teenager in a marine
sergeant who started a Facebook group
that's openly critical of President
Obama and posted comments saying he will
not follow what he says our unlawful
orders of the commander-in-chief is
facing possible dismissal dismissal from
the core the Marines told sergeant gary
Stein that he's in violation of pentagon
policy barring troops from political
activities we'll hear more about
military priorities in just a few
minutes on c-span radio and on c-span
three when General John Allen testifies
before the Senate Armed Services
Committee and those are some of the
latest headlines on c-span radio